ever since I started making division
content and uploading it to YouTube
whether it be farming videos or how to
solo a certain activity I've always
received a number of queries around the
building running with some of the more
bored comments going as far as to say
you have the best gear in the game how
the rest of us supposed to do it I've
always believed that as long as you had
a good understanding of the game and
have some sort of strategy taken from a
guide or through your own experience a
less optimized build we'll still be able
to complete the same content that your
best set can though admittedly it would
be a lot slower and more punishing with
less room for error it's all about
playing to your build strengths bad
kitty my wife having seen some of the
comments pop-up and jumping at any
opportunity to showed me that I'm wrong
told me to prove it so like every
arrogant overconfident guy out there I
laid down the challenge without really
thinking too much about the details I'd
consider myself uh maybe slightly higher
than average skill level player plus I'm
on console so you know the whole aim
thing isn't that amazing my strengths
are more from the strategy and planning
side of things and also having a fairly
good grasp on games of this type my goal
to show that any player regardless of
build should be able to complete the
most difficult PvE content in the game
they just need to play it smart
I gave Bad Kitty the job of constructing
me an average build based on what was
available for sale from the vendors this
week plus any exotics that I have in my
stash what I hadn't planned for was for
her to go straight to Reddit and with
the community's help she had prepared
the worst build I think I've ever seen
I was trying to show that an average
player in will tier five with a less
than optimized build could complete the
in-game content Purple's were off the
table and I was allowed to recalibrate
gear some suggestions were one piece
from every gear sets and any burst fire
weapon but without stating where I
should buy these I was able to be a
little bit picky with the stats and I'm
actually not too bad with burst fire
weapons so I felt this was too easy the
building ended up with was robust chests
technicians mask prosperous kneepads
did I backpack predators gloves
steadfast holster with the Midas's my
primary and the caste as my secondary
weapon first step is to decide what this
does well with without making any
changes which isn't much since most of
the pieces don't really do anything on
their own but a couple of things do
stick out straight away robust chest and
creased armor while and covered by 10%
steadfast holster health regeneration
kicks in twice as fast while in cover so
basically with two pieces that offer
cover bonuses and weapons that offer no
range and in fact hinder my damage
output I needed a way to actually take
down the NPC's because the build needs
to be able to run solo rolling it to
skill power seemed like the only way I
was going to achieve this plus with the
skill power builder be able to change up
my skills to adapt to each mission
I wanted to cover a range of activities
including light zone boss farming dark
zone farming challenging missions weekly
HVT s challenging underground legendary
Times Square and the resistance farm all
run solo I wanted to throw in a couple
of incursions - but matchmaking in New
Zealand for incursions is a painful
affair which I'm kind of glad in the
situation because I feel like a bit of
an [ __ ] joining a match made group
holding a Midas and a cassidy I could
have pulled a couple of friends together
but it would have just ended up
adjusting dear builds to make up for
where my build was falling short
as expected there really wasn't too much
difference between running one of my
best builds and the stretched ear built
[Music]
[Music]
in this example I was running the DZ
farming food division tic mostly
gathering gold caches and diptych chests
I was also taking down the odd boss -
but only if it was on my farming route
the only challenge was with the lack of
Ranger head of my weapons successful
dark zone farming is the best example of
being aware of what's going on around
you and being prepared as a solo player
with a poor build stealth is your friend
keep moving don't stop for anyone rogue
or otherwise if you find yourself in
trouble just run don't run wildly down
the middle of the street firing a gun
and every opportunity hug the buildings
always have something in front of you
and behind you run a concealed pulse and
trigger it off as often as possible keep
an eye on the kill feed it'll give you
all the information you need as far as
where the Rogues are on the map get
yourself familiar with your surroundings
plan a farming route and run it over and
over until you know every NPC every bit
of cover and all escape routes if you
need them
[Applause]
extractions
though a bit slower than the usual
speedruns are have without min/max
builds it's still perfectly achievable
with my trash tier skill power build
understanding the mission looking out
for the best cover and adjusting my
skills based on the NPC's but small
slip-ups were starting to come quite
unforgiving
[Music]
morning outsides invalid your position
you
these are actually a lot more difficult
mentioning they'd be I really had to set
camp utilizing any and all cover playing
very defensively I had to make sure I
was timing my skills I had a fresh flame
turret ready for the start of each wave
to slow down the rushes that would be
lane straight for me the other challenge
I all of the sudden had to be conscious
of was the timer
[Music]
are you talking is being
I'm not a huge fan at the underground I
think I burnt out on it a bit from
playing it too much when it was first
released in year 1 I didn't turn on any
of the modifiers it was just a straight
challenging mission this was hard but to
be honest the only things that killed me
was either me trying to rush through the
mission too quickly on a character with
no toughness or hunters almost every
time I played it I spawned hunters and
for some reason I was never prepared for
it it's like I just keep forgetting that
they could be spawned
[Music]
this OSP
challenge I'd never run the solo without
a build specifically tuned to this
mission but I feel like run it enough
times on my own to know exactly what
enemies were coming at me and where I
could take cover it took twice as long
as normal and I probably wiped at least
half a dozen times
but the key to this one was taking it
slow utilizing cover changing up my
skills throughout the mission to deal
with the different types of enemies but
to be honest if this was the only build
a ever had to work with
I'd never and thus mission solo again it
wasn't fun
hey hey no going hi
[Music]
going into this I thought I'd cuff tably
be able to make it to the wave 10 bosses
I was very wrong the best I could
consistently get to was wave 8 but
regardless of the map the waves of
shotgunners could take me down before I
could react I tried running it with
different skills I tried running to
different shd tech devices like turrets
or healing stations but it didn't matter
the bill just wasn't strong enough in
any aspect whether it be DPS toughness
or skill power the base runner dad got
me to wave teen where I was unable to
take down the bosses in time
I'll be the first to admit that this was
certainly a lot more difficult than I
was expecting but it does show that even
with a terrible build you can still
complete most of the content in the game
you just need a good understanding of
the activity and a plan of how you're
going to tackle it also I see this build
is a bit of a worst case scenario I'd
like to think that if you've made it
this far through the video that most of
you are running a much better build this
was actually quite fun attempting to
make it build out of nothing but I did
pick up a couple of things from this
activity 1 I don't mind the Mitas as
much as I thought I would I actually
grew to like it however the cassadee can
suck it hate that weapon and - when
creating some of my videos I take for
granted the top tier selection of gear
builds and weapons that I have at my
disposal and I'm not taking into
consideration the number of you that is
still trying to find the skier and may
not have the most optimized builds and
now understand the frustration I get
from some people in the comments after I
released a video titled the easy way to
get this or the fastest way to acquire
that when I'm running a completely min
Max 6 piece set that was built solely
around the specific activity these
activities can still be done but they
certainly aren't as easy in some
situations it makes sense that of all
the content are played through that it
was the resistance that I couldn't make
any decent ground on the resistance is
pretty much the only PvE in-game content
that has been released in the last 12
months
so with minimal updates to the wrists
it's the only one that is actually
balanced to the new more powerful gear
that's available so contrary to what
I've said in the past the resistance
doesn't actually increase in difficulty
too quickly with each wave it's just
that we haven't properly optimized our
builds and team collaboration adequately
as more people complete this six piece
sets or the next great new gear type
comes out it'll get easier if anything I
think the other end game activities need
to be stepped up a little for example
with this build challenging missions
should be more challenging and I
shouldn't be able to complete any
legendary missions solo in some ways the
game has become too easy for a lot of us
so when something new and challenging
comes out we're too quick to accuse it
of being too difficult don't
misunderstand me though I don't think
that the in the game content should be
locked off to everyone but the
one-percenters who have all of the gear
and knowledge but I do think as a new
more powerful gear type is added to the
game that all in-game activities
including rewards need to be adjusted
perhaps a new difficulty level so many
things released in year one have been
neglected
I'm hoping with the updates to the
underground this is a positive start to
having other game types getting a revamp
like survival and last stand
hell I'd just be happy if they made it
so I could actually play last and most
Australians and New Zealanders haven't
been able to matchmake since about two
weeks after it was released if you're a
day one player or you have most of the
gear that you could possibly need I'd
recommend trying this out it'll
certainly put your skills and game
knowledge to the test and like in my
situation it might actually help open up
your eyes and sympathize for players new
to world tier 5 I'll certainly be
helping out more in matchmaking and
dropping more in the way of rewards at
the end of each mission unless is a
cassadee I wouldn't wish that on anyone
myself I'll be trying to focus a little
more on whether my guides cater to
players with less than optimized builds
or to be more transparent with what's
required out of your builds in order to
complete what I'm showing anyway if
you've made it this far through the
video thank you very much for watching
I've actually had a lot of fun with us
using new weapons playing around with
gear I usually wouldn't touch and really
testing my knowledge of the missions if
you have any ideas for future challenges
let me know in the comments below
Cheers
[Music]